au moment où le président s'apprête à
parler le concert commence
regardez notre phrase du jour cette
allocution aurait pu être faite par chat
GPT c'est la réaction cinglante de la
nouvelle secrétaire général de la CGT le
concept d'intelligence artificielle que
la c'est bien d'ailleurs au cerveau du
président de la République il dit les
choses telles qu'il voudrait qu'elle
soit il sait tout mais il ne comprend
rien il regarde mais il ne voit pas il
écoute mais il n'entend plus à Rennes
Lille Toulouse ou Dijon les mêmes bruits
de casseroles ont retenti dans près de
300 villes des rassemblements initiés
par l'association altermondialiste
attaquent
dépenser sa popularité c'est à dire
compris que le Président de la
République avait la volonté de passer à
autre chose porte à ne pas lui faire
confiance et c'est ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui la répondu à rien il a
ignoré la colère que vous mentionnez il
n'a tenu aucun compte de ce qui s'est
passé depuis le début de cette réforme
des retraites mais il est égal à
lui-même donc là pour l'instant nous on
mobilise pour le premier mai et puis on
va continuer la mobilisation
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il était le président des riches il
devient président auto-étaire et
maintenant le président d'une France
appauvri et c'est ça ce que les Français
ont entendu hier le pire c'est qu'il
n'est rien annoncé
de l'intervention avant qu'elle n'ait eu
lieu il imaginait Macron dire le temps
de l'apaisement est venu dans un pays
profondément divisé ou de quand se sont
opposés d'un côté moi de l'autre tous
les abrutis de français aveugle à mon
génie moi un bon choix ça peut me
formule par les 100 jours assez
régulièrement en fait
il y a les 100 premiers jours
normalement on en parle au tout début
d'un mandat non mais là on est dans une
période particulière vous voyez on vient
de vivre une crise sociale forte dans
notre pays si plus de 15 millions de
Français ont suivi l'allocution
télévisée d'Emmanuel Macron ces cadres
retournés ont attiré l'attention de
nombreux téléspectateurs beaucoup de
français nous parlent à côté du sujet
des retraites de sujets du quotidien qui
leur sont chers et donc le président dit
nous allons maintenant ordonner
réorganiser notre façon de faire de la
politique sur les prochaines semaines de
manière apporter rapidement des réponses
concrètes aux problèmes que rencontrent
les Français dans leur quotidien il
s'agit de plusieurs clichés du mariage
du couple présidentiel ainsi qu'un
portrait de Charles de Gaulle un cadeau
offert par Jacques Chirac à Emmanuel
Macron lors de son élection en 2017
l'objectif qu'on doit se donner et que
l'agenda complet des négociations soit
soit définie là dans les prochaines
semaines prochaines mois de manière
solide et qu'on vous laisse le temps de
la négociation qui reste jusqu'à la fin
de cette année pour pouvoir bâtir ce
pack on sait pas faire plus vite voilà
alors on peut trouver ça un peu lent
mais en même temps je pense que le pays
gagne à ce que des accords soient signés
par le patronal syndicat la CFDT un jour
ou l'autre ira discuté mais on veut
infiniment de décence dans cette
relation là on n'est pas on nous répond
pas quand on nous siffle nos
compatriotes légitimement au nom
ras-le-bol de la fraude et j'en aurai le
bol de voir des personnes qui peuvent
toucher des aides qu'il paye eux-mêmes
c'est le contribuable qu'il paye c'est
l'entrepreneur c'est le salarié qui paye
ses aides c'est pas mon argent c'est
l'argent du contribuable il a aucune
envie de voir que des personnes peuvent
en bénéficier leur envoyer au Maghreb ou
ailleurs alors qu'ils n'y ont pas droit
réaction de Jean-Luc Mélenchon sur les
réseaux sociaux je cite chers
compatriotes musulman ou originaire
comme moi du Maghreb préparez-vous pour
faire diversion le gouvernement annonce
par la voix de Bruno Le Maire une
nouvelle campagne pour vous montrer du
doigt sans froid le vide laissé par le
Président de la République hier soir est
occupé par la pensée de l'extrême droite
et que tout simplement quand on ne sait
plus quoi dire et bien on cherche à
faire du populisme assez enfin low cost
factuellement ce qui est prévu est déjà
décidé c'est qu'à compter du 1er juillet
l'argent des prestations sociales ne
pourront plus être versés sur des
comptes à l'étranger lorsque ces comptes
sont d'origine douteuses d'accord quand
on est pas sûr que ça arrive bien à des
personnes qui relèvent de ces
prestations sociales soit je crois que
tout le monde peut être d'accord
Christian schenet qui va recevoir les
honneurs du conseil de l'or mais
pourquoi donc
c'est le plus vieux médecin de France en
exercice il a encore un peu moins de 500
patients qui le suit pour certains
depuis près de 70 ans